[Music]
straight ahead on lawn crime daily
a deadly shooting at the hands of
hollywood star alec baldwin we have
recovered what we believe to be possible
additional live rounds on set who
officials say could be charged in the
death of a cinematographer and a lengthy
jury selection in the trial for the
death of a mod arbory i don't expect a
revolt but i do expect that we're going
to have to continually thank these
jurors and remind them of how valuable
their service is to us law and crime
daily brings you the latest developments
live from georgia plus a famed tick-tock
star turned infamous ali abu laban
pleads not guilty to his wife's murder
after using his daughter's ipad to spy
on her mother and later just kept seeing
a friend of mine for 20 years that was
gunned down on her back here why the
lead detective in the markeith loyd case
says he has regrets about the
interrogation long crime daily covering
court cases from coast to coast
welcome to long crime daily everybody
i'm jesse weber in for brian buckmeyer
who's in georgia covering the ahmad
arbory trial also with me of course is
co-host terry austin new details come to
light about the fatal shooting of a
cinematographer on a movie set in new
mexico long crime's angenette levy's
here with what the sheriff and district
attorney are saying along with details
from a new search warrant
jesse both the sheriff and the district
attorney of santa fe county say it's
just far too early to determine whether
or not criminal charges will be filed
against anyone in this case but the
sheriff said during a press conference
that there was live ammunition on the
set one of those rounds killing
cinematographer cine photographer helena
hutchins
i want to ensure the victims their
families and the public
that we are conducting a thorough and
objective investigation sheriff adan
mendoza on the fatal shooting of helena
hutchins on the set of rust last
thursday mendoza says investigators
recovered the 45 caliber cult revolver
actor alec baldwin fired during
rehearsal along with two other guns one
plastic the gun had been given to
baldwin by russ's assistant director
dave halls according to a search warrant
affidavit an armorer named hannah
gutierrez was in charge of the weapons
all three individuals have been
cooperative in the investigation
and have provided statements the sheriff
says 500 rounds were recovered from the
set some dummies some blanks and some
live ammunition
we suspect that there was other live
rounds that were found on the set i
won't comment further on how they got
there that's still part of a
this investigation is active so i won't
comment on how they got there helena
hutchins died director joel souza was
wounded but will anyone face charges the
sheriff and the d.a say it's too early
to tell
if the facts and evidence and law
support charges then i will initiate
prosecution at that time you never
sacrifice safety for convenience bobby
chacon is a former fbi agent who works
on television shows as an advisor an
affidavit for a third search warrant
reveals armorer hannah gutierrez told
investigators live ammo is never kept on
the set gutierrez also told
investigators she handed the gun to both
alec baldwin that day and dave halls the
affidavit says halls told investigators
he could only see three rounds in the
gun before continuing rehearsal and said
he should have checked all of them but
didn't and couldn't recall whether
hannah spun the drum of the revolver to
make sure it was clear
so you always do a double check you
everybody checks it everybody that's
handling that weapon always checks it
should always check it and that's how
you avoid you know saying oh well
somebody else told me
now a report by the wrap
reported that there were actually
members of the film crew
doing uh target practice during the
lunch break it's called plinking they
were shooting at beer cans they call it
plinking because of the sound that it
makes when the bullet hits the beer can
sheriff mendoza was actually asked about
that during the press conference and he
said he could not comment on where the
live ammunition came from since this is
an active and ongoing investigation
jesse all right let's talk about it
we're joined now by co-host terry austin
and also legal analyst dina dahl dina
let me start with you the santa fe
county district attorney says that no
charges are off the table in this case
but what is the likelihood that alec
baldwin himself could face charges not
only as the person who fired the weapon
but he was a producer on the movie maybe
meaning he had added responsibility
it's a unique situation at the person
who fired the gun alec is most likely
least gonna be culpable for any criminal
charges because it would have been
reasonable for him to have relied on the
announcement of cold gun that's typical
for actors and for it to be a criminal
charge he would have had to act
recklessly but as a producer the
producers could very well be found to
have been unreasonable in their actions
which would result in civil liability
whether or not the producers acted
recklessly i mean it's far too soon to
tell on that situation terry there was
at least one report that said russ
producers had hired a law firm to also
investigate the incident what do you
think about that
i think it means they're taking this
case very seriously they hired the law
firm of jenner and block it's a
chicago-based firm with over 500 lawyers
they've been around since 1914 and
they're investigating the shooting also
osha which is the occupational health
and safety administration is on this
site and they are also investigating and
so the producers basically sent a memo
to the entire cast saying listen osha is
on site you must preserve all evidence
and that actually includes emails yeah
and maybe they're getting ahead of a
lawsuit uh and janette what did the
sheriff say about the round that killed
hutchins
well as i mentioned earlier it was a
live round he confirmed that today and
that was the suspicion all along but he
also said that they recovered that from
the shoulder of director joel souza he
was wounded in the shooting so he said
they were actually able to recover
the bullet and the the shell casing as
well and those items have been sent to
the fbi lab in quantico virginia for
analysis yeah well with multiple people
looking into this we're probably going
to have more answers moving forward
thanks so much ange appreciate it
switching gears now to south carolina
where multiple lawsuits claim that
controversial attorney alec murdoch may
be hiding millions of dollars in three
separate civil lawsuits attorneys say
they fear murdoch may be relocating his
money after he made remaining son buster
responsible for his financial affairs
two of the lawsuits stemmed from the
family of mallory beach who was killed
in a boating crash in 2019. murdoch's
now deceased son paul was charged for
driving drunk and recklessly the other
lawsuit was filed by the family of
gloria satterfeld the murdoch
housekeeper who died at the family's
home in 2018. alec murdoch is charged
with illegally obtaining nearly three
million dollars worth of insurance
settlements that were meant for
satterfeld's estate all this just the
latest twist in the so-called murdoch
murder mystery in june murdoch's wife
maggie and son paul were found dead on
their family property now murdoch has
been named a person of interest in the
case but no charges have been filed in
september murdoch claimed that he was
shot in the head while changing a flat
tire but he later revealed it was all
part of a botched
suicide-by-hire plan meant to leave
remaining sun buster with an insurance
payout right now murdoch is being held
in a south carolina jail without bond
and still ahead on lawn crime in daily a
famous tick tocker pleads not guilty
after prosecutors say he shot and killed
his influencer wife before picking up
their daughter from school but first
jury selection and the trial for the
death of ahmad arbory stretches into
another day long crime daily's brian
buckmeyer is live in georgia with the
latest in the case
[Music]
it was the video that shocked the nation
an unarmed black jogger 25 year old
ahmad abre gunned down in broad daylight
we are going to make sure that we find
justice in this case the three men
charged will now stand trial i told him
stop stop stop till he hit me i had
nothing to do
i could i just nothing else i can do
you're a pastor buyer coming through not
necessarily
that's my son that shot him i was at the
back of the truck
starting october 18th watch live galvado
gavel coverage on the law and crime
network
[Music]
and welcome back everybody a week and a
half into jury selection and some are
expressing concern at the lengthy
process in the death of a mod arbory
trial three men face charges including
malice murder felony murder and
aggravated assault in the shooting of 25
year old ahmad arbory prosecutors say
that arbory was jogging near his
brunswick georgia neighborhood in
february 2020 when he was tailed by
father and son gregory and travis
mcmichael travis mcmichael opened fired
and killed arbory now claiming
self-defense william roddy bryan
followed along in his own vehicle
recording the incident on his cell phone
jury selection began for all three men
last monday in glen county georgia and
that is where brian buckmeyer joins us
now live and brian it's good to see you
you spoke with travis mcmichael's
attorney earlier this afternoon about
that lengthy jury selection process
correct
i did i spoke to him about the lengthy
jury selection process and also some of
the words shared by some of his
co-counsel saying that this process
seems to be going along in a very kind
of arduous and long way that he felt and
was worried that there may be in his
words a revolt where some of these uh
off some of these uh individuals may not
actually come back to court but before
we get to that part i want to talk about
how we started this morning with 36 of
64 of those prospective jurors 19
prospective jurors came in today we
found out that five were
african-american uh out those three were
women and two were men found out earlier
just before we got on actually that we
have six now prospective jurors that are
joining so adding to that 36 we're at 42
now getting closer and closer to that
64. now wamps is trying to move things
forward but as i said earlier about this
the defense shared concerns about a
revolt or concerns of the length of the
process could cause a loss of jurors in
this case
the jury service is not just about
sitting in the trial of the case it's
also about coming to court it's about
waiting around it's about waiting to see
if you get picked and there's a lot of
that that's happening in this case and
it's happening because of the coverage
of this case and the time that we have
to take with the jurors who are sitting
right in front of us during jury
selection and so
i'm sure that there are people waiting
who feel like they have other things
they need to be doing that they want to
be doing that they're concerned or
worried about
but
we're still asking that they be patient
with us that if it was their
son or father that if it was their
relative or family member that was on
trial like the mcmichael czar in this
case that they would hope for jurors who
would be patient and understanding
brian do you get the sense that as this
trial progresses once the jury is
selected that we might lose jurors based
on everything that's going on in the
courthouse and outside of the courthouse
i would hope not jessie and the reason
why i say that
in other cases yes maybe but the way
that the judge in this case as well as
all the attorneys are really trudging
through all of these prospective
jurors really gives me some bit of
confidence that there may not be
problems down the road they're letting
people who have any kind of issues
whether it be child care issues health
care issues traveling issues to get off
the case and they're really trying to
drill down to that 12 and four
alternates that can carry this case well
let's get into that from your
perspective you're in georgia do you
think that jury selection could be
wrapped up by the end of the week or
will it be extended into another week
and we'll have to wait even longer for
opening statements
so like i said earlier we started with
36 today six more just got added as i
was actually speaking with you jesse so
we're at 42 of that uh 64. but we're
seeing jurors added four
six seven a day and so if we're just
kind of guesstimating based on those
average numbers i think we more likely
than not could be pulling ourselves into
next week where we can have jury
selection into monday or tuesday because
we still have to whittle down from that
64 that we're not at yet down to 12
jurors and four alternates with those
preemptory strikes i am sure there will
be a battle in the courtroom about that
and it will not be so easy but we will
wait and see and we're going to hear
more from brian buckmeyer who's
reporting live brian thank you so much
appreciate it
on to federal court right now where a
third juror is dismissed in the fraud
trial of former theranos ceo elizabeth
holmes this now raising concerns as the
trial is expected to continue into
december the trial began in early
september and just days later the first
juror was dismissed due to financial
hardship and work schedule then weeks
later a second juror was dismissed after
anxiety surrounding a religious belief
then you go to last friday a third juror
was dismissed after another juror
reported that they were playing a sudoku
puzzle during testimony now in all 12
jurors were selected with just five
alternates holmes is charged with 12
counts of fraud for her work at the now
defunct theranos she claimed that the
company and its devices would
revolutionize blood testing but later
tests found that there were many
problems with the equipment
coming up on long crime daily the state
of florida versus markeith lloyd jurors
hear from the lead detective on the case
plus a tick-tocker with nearly 1 million
followers now behind bars without bail
what prosecutors say led up to the
double murder of his wife and her friend
[Music]
welcome back everybody a tick tock star
is charged with the murder of his wife
and her friend in their san diego
apartment ali abu laban is mostly known
for his comedy skits on tiktok where
he's known as jin kidd there he's famous
for his impersonations of tony montana
from scarface but investigators say abu
laban was living at a hotel after his
wife kicked him out of their apartment
on october 18th on thursday while his
wife wasn't home the tick tocker
allegedly snuck back into their
apartment trashed the place and
installed a listening app in their app
on their five-year-old daughter's ipad
investigators say that he was operating
under the assumption that his wife was
cheating on him while listening to the
device abu laban heard a man's voice got
angry and rushed back to the apartment
that's where he allegedly shot 29 year
old kadenas baron three times and then
shot his wife anna abulaban in the head
after that investigators say he picked
up his daughter from school while he was
still carrying the murder weapon he
allegedly called his mother and the
police and confessed to the shooting the
tick tock star has pled not guilty to
the two counts of first-degree murder
and remains behind bars with no bail
so terry this case seems you know fairly
straightforward what kind of defense
could he assert
well we're in california and he could be
charged with voluntary manslaughter
which would give him the defense that he
was acting in a heat of passion that he
had this strong sudden impulse and
that's very common when you have someone
who thinks that they are being cheated
on it means basically that there was no
malice a4 thought meaning that he wasn't
planning this but it's still a felony
jesse and he could get 11 years for each
of the counts the other defense i think
he could claim insanity but there he'd
have to show did he know the difference
between right and wrong so it's an
interesting case for sure well deena
authorities say abelaban confessed to
his mother and police after the murders
but ended that not guilty plea you know
how do you fight against those
confessions i feel like they're going to
sway a verdict in this case if it goes
to a jury
absolutely it's going to be one of the
largest pieces of evidence because they
can't even even really claim that
somehow it was coerced because he
voluntarily confessed to both of them
you know hopefully this case also
highlights that despite your fame
despite your economics despite what you
look like domestic violence is real he
has a history of domestic violence so
but against her so between that and the
confessions they have a very strong gaze
against him i guess the other way of
looking at it was given so high profile
does shed a light on maybe those issues
that don't always get the most attention
we're going to continue follow that one
when we come back the second murder
trial for defendant markeith lloyd hear
from the lead detective who testifies
about his emotional interrogation of the
defendant we'll be back
and welcome back testimony continues in
florida for the man accused of shooting
and killing lieutenant debra clayton
clayton was gunned down outside of a
walmart while she was pursuing defendant
mark keith lloyd in january 2017. at the
time lloyd was running from authorities
after killing his pregnant ex-girlfriend
shade dixon in 2019 lloyd was found
guilty of dicks and mer dixon's murder
and was sentenced to life in prison
dodging the death penalty however if
convicted in this case lloyd will face
the death penalty again on tuesday the
lead detective took the stand to talk
about his investigation on direct
examination he was questioned about his
emotions while he interrogated the
defendant
tell mr lloyd that he quote led a
gutless life i did
and did you tell him apologize for
language your honor did you call him
a in body armor
i did
you called him a punk
i did
and a quote
i did
and you said that he didn't deserve the
respect of any rabid dog on the street
did you say that to him i did it's
extremely unprofessional for me to say
that
and to this day four years later i beat
myself out constantly as to you know why
i allowed that to come out just kept
seeing a friend of mine for 20 years
that was
gunned down on her back and it triggered
something in me that i just never
experienced before and again i don't
want to sound like an excuse but
that's my thoughts came out of my mouth
and they shouldn't have
do you know we just heard some pretty
damning testimony from the lead
detective in the case the question is do
you think the jury's gonna care i mean
does this help in any way lloyd's case
that he had a delusional belief that the
officers were out to kill him if you
hear this animosity
it certainly helps i mean that's one of
the few things he is arguing is that
there was this excessive police force
that as a black man he was being
targeted and this does lead into it
those types of statements but i believe
that his apology came across very
sincere and sympathetic as he said this
police officer was gunned down and she
was a friend and when you see the video
surveillance and really the facts of the
case you know i don't think that that
defensive um excessive police force is
legitimate in this case well it is
interesting that the the prosecution who
was questioning him kind of got out in
front of it they didn't hide this it's
not as if the defense just jumped in and
said didn't you say this no they got in
front of it now terry let me ask you
this about the defense they have spent a
considerable amount of time trying to
show that the that clayton was the first
to fire that she was the aggressor again
going into this narrative that he wanted
to kill lloyd you think it's being
effective because we're almost mostly
hearing under cross examination
i don't think that's effective at all i
think the ballistics is going to show
something different and what difference
does it make we know for a fact
that clayton was out there searching for
a killer and we know that she also said
to get down don't shoot and
we know that lloyd actually shot her
four different times he had three shots
that were not deadly and then he went
back over to shoot her to do the death
shot essentially so i think the fact
that the defense is spending time on who
shot first and clayton was shooting at
him is irrelevant and i think the jury
is going to see straight through that
well the insanity defense is always
interesting to hear and let alone in
this case dina dahl terry austin thank
you so much everyone out there thanks
for joining us here on long crime daily
we'll see you next time as we discuss
justice in america
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you